in a turn of events that surprise
exactly no 1 Star Wars The Force awakens
became one of the biggest hits of the
past several years and scored some
pretty great reviews to boot it borrowed
heavily from the first Star Wars film
sure but it sprinkled enough fresh ideas
to balance out the nostalgia perfectly
so the film is pretty great but that
doesn't mean there aren't a few things
in there that might make you scratch
your head here are the dumb things we
all ignored in Star Wars The Force
awakens so what's the first orders whole
deal anyway in the original Star Wars
trilogy the rebellion fights for freedom
from the tyranny of the Empire the
Empire is well an empire it's a huge
evil government that rules the galaxy
with an iron fist makes sense right but
in the force awakens it's the resistance
that fights against the first order and
the first order is what exactly
if the rebellion defeated the Empire and
the galaxy is now governed by the New
Republic then what the heck is the first
order what do they do and why and we're
thinking the resource is to build an
entire planet made of Death Star's
curious fans can hit up Google for the
first orders of explained backstory but
seriously we shouldn't have to chase
down the answer to some pretty basic
questions by digging into the force
awakens visual dictionary the kids buy
at elementary school book fairs r2d2 is
perfect timing
that little data file that led to Luke's
hidden location served as a great carrot
to dangle in front of everyone and keep
this movie rolling if there's one thing
Star Wars does great it's hiding
important information and adorable
robots what message the one you've just
been kidding the one you're carrying
inside your rusty innards
but bb-8 only has a piece of the map so
naturally the little guy wonder is about
the other droid who spent some time as a
rolling flashdrive r2d2 in fact he asks
r2 about whether or not he's got the
rest of the map everybody needs and then
this happens
you're wasting your time
it is very doubtful that r2 would have
the rest of the map in his backup data I
am afraid not
r2d2 has been in low-power mode ever
since master Luke went away but c-3po is
totally wrong as we find out at the end
of the film when r2 suddenly wakes up
just in time to put everybody back into
a good mood that's great timing r2 but
hadn't the resistance ever tried to look
through Artoo's memory before he
literally has a computer for a brain
nobody dug out a USB cable and plugged
him into the computer no one in the
resistance is heard of control-f captain
phasma is not very fantastic captain
phasma is undeniably cool what with a
shiny armor fancy cape and slick British
accent and then she goes down like a
sack of potatoes and then she pretty
much caves immediately Finn tells her to
bring down the shield's across the base
and she does it without a fight did she
only get that fancy stormtrooper suit
because she's like general Hux his
cousin or something honks don't need
parachutes remember when Finn and Poe
crash land on jakku and Finn takes Poe's
jacket from the smoking wreckage it sure
seemed like Poe was dead until he showed
up again for the last act of the movie
we never find out how he survived or
even why he left his style and jacket
behind the reason Poe was actually dead
at least in the first bunch of drafts of
the screenplay
apparently director JJ Abrams was so
taken with Oscar Isaacs performance he
decided to keep ho around after all too
bad we can't say the same for every
pilot in Star Wars of course cover me
Porkins I'm right with your rhetoric
checked I can hold it
sorry Porkins should have been handsomer
a convenient chasm the film ends with a
climactic battle between Rey and kylo
Ren and she takes the email Vader
wannabe to the woodshed by the end of
the fight kylo Ren has a few holes in
them andreas triumphant then a very
convenient hole opens up right between
them allowing ren to be rescued before
the Starkiller base explodes this of
course is highly symbolic of the
ideological divide between Rey and kylo
Ren one is embarked on the path of the
Jedi while the other has turned his back
on it forever good versus evil dark
versus light oh and keeping your
exciting new bad guy alive so he can
come back and give your heroes a hard
time in the sequel too bad we can't say
the same for every exciting new bad guy
in Star Wars of course
[Music]
sorry Darth Maul should have been a kylo
Ren ear thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out this other cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]